cette affreuse badra l'enfance et les
ports complet complet 1971
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
madame il est question de stérilité sur
le plateau pour témoigner que des femmes
longtemps désigné comme seul coupable de
la stérilité d'impôts mais le discours
et les mentalités commencent à changer
l'homme n'était absolument intouchable
et je crois que le problème de l'homme
n'est véritablement connu que depuis
mettons 20 30 un homme et femme sont
donc considérés tous les deux comme
potentiellement responsables mais outre
ce changement de mentalité
dès les années 70 un autre coupable est
pointé du doigt le mode de vie la
fatigue les dépressions nerveuses qu'on
appelle le stress eux l'environnement
qui est mal adaptée et c est ce que
cette vie modem peut être responsable de
nouvelles formes de stérilité
à cette question les professeurs de
l'époque répondent oui
il énumère plusieurs facteurs comme les
effets secondaires de la contraception
chez les femmes où l'augmentation du
nombre de maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
on en voit de plus en plus ça peut
bouger les trompes ça peut boucher chez
l'homme les canaux qui transportent les
spermatozoïdes c'est une nouvelle forme
de stérilité de nouvelles formes de
stérilité qui se vérifie dès les années
70 les scientifiques étudient la qualité
du sperme en 1973 un homme de 35 ans
avait 89 millions de spermatozoïdes par
millilitre de sperme ses 73 millions en
1989 et 60 millions en 1992 dans les
années 90 d'ailleurs nouveau facteur de
stérilité
les perturbateurs endocriniens des
chercheurs de l'inserm ont remis
aujourd'hui un rapport d'expertisé
concernant les éthers de glycol il
s'agit de solvants que l'on retrouve
dans les peintures les shampooings ou
les produits d'entretien et d'après
cette étude
il aurait des effets dramatiques sur la
santé il provoquerait la stérilité pour
les adultes 2005 la concentration de
spermatozoïdes diminue encore passant à
50 millions par millilitre de sperme
en 2008 le ministère de l'environnement
s'empare de la question mais aucune
réglementation restrictive
en revanche des conseils plutôt légers
face aux risques éviter la
multiplication des cosmétiques si
cosmétiques il ya aller plutôt vers le
bio au moins le sans paraben pour
l'entretien de la maison prendre des
produits verts en 2015 première mesure
forte la france interdit le bisphénol a
notamment présent dans les biberons mais
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt car
aujourd'hui les perturbateurs
endocriniens sont partout dans les
pesticides les cosmétiques certains
aliments dans les solvants et le bras de
fer entre lobby de la chimie et l'union
européenne pour réglementer leur
utilisation est loin d'être terminée
[Musique]